we lost a chance in 2016 to like someone
that I think would have beaten Trump or
the very least would have you know
been close do you think the Democrats
screwed him over
that's not in the way of deliberate or
direct vote working but
they put their thumb on the scale uh for
sure I mean there's there's it's not
even conspiracy theory there's all this
stuff in the debates about uh Clinton
you know being Clinton's people being
fed questions and and whatever else and
just the tone of the media the media was
extremely dismissive and hostile uh to
him uh I love that Bernie still does the
Fox News town hall because they're just
him speaking to the people and he's not
afraid of of going on you know any sort
of
um outlet and making his uh his case but
I think a lot of the the liberal media
in particular
um always had it out for Bernie Sanders
what was the because that was really
annoying that was really annoying how
dismissive they were I I've seen that in
some other candidates like um they were
dismissive towards Andrew Yang in that
same way so forget the ideology
why are they so smug sometimes towards
certain candidates what is that because
I think that's actually at the core to a
degree of Democrats or any party fails
that it's that smugness because people
see through that I think a lot of these
people are friends even if they don't
know each other their friends because
they went to the same schools they know
the same people they have the same broad
just ideology and worldview so they had
a sense of what the Democratic party
should be and who it should be running
and who is going to win and also what
was serious and unserious yeah so Bernie
would say some things about the world
that objectively to a lot of people seem
correct or at least
pretty close to correct and a journalist
would just look at him like he's from
outer space to some extent this also
happens on to people on the right you
know people on the right often say
things that I find uh repulsive or or
just wrong but
there's parts of the media that would
describe their certain views as
illegitimate or outside this boundaries
of acceptable conversation I think there
should be a few things outside the
boundary of acceptable conversation you
know hate speech and and so on but like
there's this attempt to say
their views are illegitimate and
therefore anyone who votes for them for
any reason is illegitimate too and
that's one reason why I think it fueled
a lot of resentment and it will
ultimately end up feeling
um the extremes of American politics
that people feel like you know they're
they're not being listened to yeah and
some of it is also style speaking and
personality
where if you're not willing to sort of
play kind of a game of Civility
there's like a proper way of speaking if
you're a Democrat if you're not doing
that kind of proper way of speaking
people dismiss you I think in certain
sense whatever you feel about him people
dismiss Donald Trump for the same reason
where it's the style of speaking the
personality of the person that he's not
playing by the rules of of polite
Society of polite politician society and
so on
and that that's really
that troubles me because it feels like
Solutions the great leaders
will not be polite
in the they're not they're not going to
behave in their the way they're supposed
to behave and I just wish the media was
at least open-minded to that like
which I guess gives me hope about the
New Media which is like more distributed
citizen media right that they're more
open mind to the Revolutionary
to The Outsiders right I actually first
uh I really like Bernie Sanders
um I first heard him
on uh in conversation with Thom Hartmann
uh he had these like uh like weekly
conversations and just the authenticity
from the guy I didn't even know any
context I didn't even know honestly he
was a Democratic Socialist or anything
the authenticity of the human being was
really refreshing and we I guess decided
to run for president that was really
strange I was like surely this kind of
this person has no chance
just like he seemed too authentic he
seemed to
like he's not going to be effective at
playing the game of politics so it was
very inspiring to me to see that you
don't necessarily need to be good at
playing the game of politics you can
actually have a chance of winning yeah
that was that was really inspiring to
see